tell me about it oh
no I don't think I can do
it hey everybody I'm WWE Superstar
Bianca valair and I'm WWE Superstar one
half of the street profits montz Ford
and these are our favorite
[Music]
snacks
I'm montz and this is my snack combo the
classic sour punch straws strawberry no
not even strawberry Red Red flavor is
they say what flavor red now they good
by themselves but what I do is after you
take your straw you put that mud right
there and you sitp oh like an actual
sour
straw see you smart come on with it come
on with it tell me about it
I maybe got a teaspoon of
sprite oh ooh the sugar gets stuck on
your lips so it's like the Sprite and
then the sweetness of the sugar that's
right it's a nice little combo tell me
about it oh this is hit you know what I
you should do too look I take it up a n
too let me tell you about it
[Music]
ready
m
m i put my blood pressure and then at
the end when you eat it it got the
Sprite on there I just
W you did
that you did that
one this is one of my favorite snacks it
actually takes me back to my childhood
it might seem a little weird but don't
knock it till you try it okay what child
eats what this is a brick it's a dill
pickle with the orange popcorn salt okay
this goes back to high school the
basketball games with the concession
stand when they sold they sold the deal
pickles and they sold the popcorn and
for some reason we would get the deal
Pickle and you dip it in the in the
popcorn salt and you just eat it and
it's
like you make that face oh cuz it gives
that it's that kick now in high school
we used to just like coat
it that's the face you got to
make but it's really good you do get the
little face at the end you still up mhm
that's when you know it's working yeah
it is so woo now you ready for the
basketball game
[Music]
yeah egg
whites you can't you can explain this
what is how you consume it what what's
wrong with consuming it it's you
supposed to you drink it how is it
supposed to go down now I only need
about like maybe 8 oz but it's a quick
snack and I don't have to take the
skillet out making dirty dishes or
anything like that like you know what
just get some egg whites pour in the cup
measure it boy you going to catch
salmonella how look it says best if
youed
oh let me see how quick this is okay you
ready just start
counting One Mississippi two Mississippi
three Miss Mississippi for look at the
consistency oh no it looks like I don't
want to say what it look like oh my
God you know you don't like
that you don't like it I do this every
morning boom that's half of it that's my
half my serving jug jug jug jug jug jug
jug jug I don't think I can do
it I kind of feel like crying right now
no don't do it don't do it no no peer
pressure no don't do it I want to be a
good
sport there we go
[Music]
see it don't taste like nothing don't
taste like nothing that's what I'm
saying well that's why I do it all the
time it don't taste like
nothing
a see I'm excited about this this is my
second snack Crispy Cream original
glazed donuts and this is special to us
cuz we actually had Crispy Cream Donuts
at our wedding we did I am not spending
$1,000 on a wedding cake that nobody's
going to eat anyway cuz nobody eats the
wedding cake and plus I ain't got
$1,000 everybody ate them up they ate
them up I mean everybody everybody ate
them yeah everybody this is like not
just one person cuz that would be
selfish toast wait no wedding oh yeah
that's right
no what are you
no we couldn't figure out the wedding
either are you
ready something's never
changed okay
go this brings back memories from the
wedding next is my snack my
snack
[Music]
no I'm just crying
just the Classic the
goat
Doritos nachos shoes you tell me
anywhere in the world you ever seen this
chip Super Bowl parties holiday parties
this chip is there it's the goat go with
the goat it's the goat
boom no no it's okay no you you left me
hanging I just toast
[Laughter]
myself it's the goat would say with the
wrestling world this is the John Cena
because everybody knows it everybody's
seen it they seen
it or have they seen it or have they
seen
it this is my next snack it is a jelly
sandwich no peanut butter just jelly all
right what it's just jelly no peanut
butter I don't really snack a lot I'm
not a big snacker cuz I'm I'm a wrestler
so I eat healthy but when I do snack I
like to go back to like my childhood
snack so this is another childhood snack
growing up we always ate jelly
sandwiches I don't think I had a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich until maybe
middle school but the the trick is you
put so much jelly on there that when you
bite it the jelly like squeezes out you
put it on both I'm a both Sider both of
them both of them both of them both b f
e m and it's not supposed to be pretty
okay see how when you squeeze it see
that jelly oo oh that's what you know
it's going to be
good M this just makes me so happy look
at
[Music]
that and then you eat it and when you
finish you eat all the jelly too well
I'll be
there
[Music]
well once again this is w Superstar
montz Ford and to my right your left the
EST of the WWE Bianca Belair and thank
you for watching us snack on our
favorite snacks make sure to tune in to
Hulu February 2nd 2024 for our reality
TV show love and
WWE that's us loud direct and effect
love you guys boom stay bless and stay
[Applause]
[Music]
Snacky